[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم
الاسطوره بتقول ان اطفال متلازمه داون
كلهم ليهم نفس الشكل والقدرات واطار النمو
مش بس كده احنا في كتير كمان مننا مصدق ان
الاطفال عامه المفروض يكبروا ويتربوا
ويتعلموا بنفس الطريقه الحقيقه ان ده كان
تفكيري انا كمان من 11 سنه وعشان اغير
الفكره دي عديت برحله طويله ما بين
الانكار والربط والكبول
الحكايه ابتدت
من ابني ان انا كان عندي حلم ان انا اخلف
طفل واسميه علي وفعلا علي جيل الدنيا بس
يوم ورا يوم وشهر ورا شهر علي بيكبر بس
بيكبر بشكل مختلف شويه يمكن عينيه ضيقه
شعره ناعم طفل هادي شويتين بس تمام ما فيش
ام مش عايزه ابنها يكون طفل هادي وكيوت
وجميل
بس انا قلبي كان بيقول لي ان في حاجه
مختلفه عند علي
وعشان كده روحنا لدكتور واتنين وتلاته لحد
ما وصلنا للدكتور الرابع وقال لنا ابنكم
عنده متلازمه
طبعا انا قلت مين الدكتور اللي مش فاهم
حاجه ده الحاجات دي احنا بنشوفها في
الشارع نشوفها في التلفزيون نقراها على
السوشيال ميديا لكن تحصل لنا اكيد لا
وبعدين كده كده انا وبابا مش قرايب وما
فيش حاجه زي دي في عيلتنا فاكيد لا بس
قلنا تمام يعني عشان نطمن هنروح نعمل
التحليل وفعلا عملنا التحليل مره واتنين
واكيد انتم متخيلين النتيجه كانت ايه
بالظبط تم تشخيص علي متلازمه داون وهو
عنده تسع شهور لحظه وقف عندها الزمن كل
حاجه بقت ضلمه الحلم اتحول لكابوس والبنت
اللي كانت بتحلم تخلف طفله عشان تلعب معه
بقت مسؤوله عن طفل مختلف في وسط مجتمع
معظمه مش بيتقابل الاختلاف والاول مره في
حياتي يبقى مضطره اكثر احكم على الناس من
بره لان خلاص ابني بقى عنده تشخيص واضح
عليه فاكيد انا مش عايزه اعمل فيه كده ولا
عايزه الناس تعمل فيه كده
منكرش وقتها ان انا كنت خايفه كنت خايفه
لان انا كنت جاهله ولان الانسان عدو هيجهل
قررت اروح اقرا واتعلم اكتر عن متلازمه
داون والحقيقه ان انا عرفت معلومات كتيره
قوي عرفت ان الاسم الصحيح هو متلازم
الدعوه او
دانسن روم مش ان هو اسمه طفل عرفت
ان كلمه داون اصلا معناها باسم الطبيب
اللي اكتشف التشخيص مش معناه ان هو داون
او ان هو اقل من اي حد عرفت كمان ان هو اه
خلل جيني بس مش لازم ابدا يكون وراثي ومش
لازم يكون انا وبابا السبب وان 95% من
الحالات بتكون بسبب طفره جينيه مش حاجه
وراثيه عرفت كمان ان اطفال متلازمه داون
يقدروا يتكلموا ويتعلموا ويدخلوا مدارس
وجامعات ويشتغلوا لو اتقدم لهم خدمه تدخل
مبكر جيده وان مش لازم ابدا الطفل متلازمه
داون يكون عنده قصور ذهني
اللي كان مؤسف بالنسبه لي ان انا لقيت ان
في ناس متخصصين في المجال الطبي او
التعليمي او التاهيلي عندهم معلومات قديمه
او مغلوطه عن متلازمه داون زي مثلا الكتاب
ده ده كتاب بيتدرس في جامعه عندنا هنا
شايفين عنوان الكتاب ايه بالظبط التخلف
العقل فده مستوى العلم اللي بيتقدم واحنا
لسه بعيد قوي في الجزء ده
مش بس كده انا اكتشفت ان الاماكن المخصصه
لاستقبال الاطفال في كتير منها اصلا بيرفض
استقبال اطفال مختلفين زي المدارس
والحضانات ومثلا مش هنلاقي الاماكن العامه
فيها تصبح للاطفال على ويلي تشير ان هم
يتحركوا بحريه زي ما يكون كانهم مش
موجودين ومثلا مش هنلاقي في اماكن لعب
اطفال او كيدز اريا بتوفر اماكن تسمح
للاطفال العناوين الشير او اللي عندهم
مشاكل سمعيه وبصريه او حسيه ان هم يبقوا
جواها ومن ده كتير
بعد ما اتاكدنا خلاص من تشخيص علي ابتدينا
مرحله التدخل مبكر مع دكاتره ومتخصصين بس
ده لوحده بالنسبه لي ما كانش كفايه قوي
قررت ابص واشوف ليفيا اطفال تطورها احسن
من اطفال تانيين ليه في اطفال بتقدر تعمل
حاجات واطفال تانيه لا ايه الفرق يعني
اكيد الفرق مش بس في المكان الاطفال دي
مولوده فيه اكيد الفرق في العلم والخدمه
المقدمه عشان كده رحت درست اكتر على تضخم
مبكر ورحت سافرت كذا مكان عشان اتعلم اكثر
عن
وازاي نقدر نساعد الاطفال المختلفين اللي
عندهم مشاكل جينيه وتنمويه انه قدراتهم
تبقى احسن
لقيت نفسي مش بساعد عليه لقيت نفسي بساعد
علي واطفال تانيين وامهات كمان عشان ما
حدش فيهم يحس ان هو لوحده زي ما انا كنت
بحس زمان
ومن هنا جت فكره بنط بوند هو مجتمع بيضم
اباء وامهات عندهم اطفال مختلفين وهدفنا
فيه ان احنا نتشارك نتشارك الخبرات
والتجارب والمشاعر والافكار عشان ما حدش
فينا يحس ان هو لوحده وعشان اللي مش السكه
دي قبل كده يساعد غيره ان هو يكمل
احنا بقى لنا دلوقتي ثلاث سنين مع الامهات
بنقدم خدمات مختلفه بنقدم خدمات الدعم
النفسي والدعم الاسري ورش عمل على التدخل
مبكر والدمج التعليمي وبنعلم الامهات كل
حاجه تخص ولادنا
مش بس علي هو بطل الحكايه دي ليل يا اخت
علي الصغيره هي جزء كبير من حكايتنا ليه
يا طفله عندها قدر كبير من التقبل
والتسامح لاي حد مختلف عنها ايا كان شكله
او دينه او لونه او جنسه او حتى قدراته
لانها اتربت في بيت في طفل مختلف فبقت
شايفه انه ده عادي وان هو اه مختلف عنها
بس هو مش اقل منها في اي حاجه
بيعرف يعمل حاجات كثيره قوي علي في مدرسه
عاديه فور بيقدر يتكلم ويتعلم وبيقرا
وبيكتب وبيعمل كل حاجه زي زبائن الاطفال
مش بس كده عليه كمان بيلعب درامز والشهر
الجاي هيكون عنده البيرفورمنس ليه على
المسرح علي كمان من احلامه ان هو يبقى شاف
اوقات كثيره المجتمع هو اللي بيكون معيق
بسبب رفض المجتمع للاختلاف رفض المجتمع
للاختلاف بيخليه الام تحس ان هي وابنها
كانهم من كوكب ثاني وانها محتاجه تاخد
ابنها وتمشي بعيد علشان ما حدش يرفضها مع
ان انا لو عرفنا الاختلاف ده سنه الحياه
وان هو رحمه من ربنا على الارض وان ربنا
اصلا خلقنا مختلفين عشان نتعلم ونتشارك
اكيد حياتنا هتبقى احسن واسهل كتير
ليه انا بقول الكلام ده النهارده بقول
الكلام ده النهارده لان انتم مستقبل ابني
انتم المجتمع اللي هو هيعيش فيه واذا كان
المجتمع ده دامج ومتقبل الاختلاف اكيد
حياته حياه اطفال كتير زيه هتبقى احسن
واسهل كتير
الدمجه حق بيقفلوا القانون المصري لكن
ناقصنا بجد ان المجتمع ده يكون دامج وتقبل
للاختلاف
بشجعكم جدا انتم تقروا وتعرفوا اكتر عن
الفروقات الفرديه بين الاطفال وعن
الاختلافات وعن الاعاقات عامه وتقرا
وتعرفوا اكتر عن اتيكات او اداب التعامل
مع ذوي الاعاقه لان دي حاجه بتفرق جدا في
نفسيه الام والطفل
اخر حاجه عايزه اقولها لكم ان احنا كلنا
كلنا مختلفين عن بعض بشكل او باخر وكلنا
محتاجين الناس تقبلنا برغم اختلافنا كل
طفل وليه حكايه مختلفه اسمعوا قصص الاطفال
وما تمشوش ورا الاسطوره شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]